welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar digital
biosensors and the Internet of biology
presented by dr. Brett goldsmith CTO of
Cordia my name is Susie Valdes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box and let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits without further ado please join
me in welcoming our presenter today dr.
brett goldsmith welcome dr. Goldsmith
thank you without further ado I will get
started on the presentation it's my
pleasure to talk to everyone I'm gonna
be talking today about digital
biosensors and the Internet of biology
and there's some words in there that are
probably and familiar to you and that's
okay my name is Brett goldsmith I'm the
CTO and co-founder of cardia and I am a
nanotechnologist and a physicist so that
that may color some of the talk of
you're about to see to begin talking
about the Internet of biology I want to
start with biological networks violent
hill networks are something that we're
just now starting to understand there
combinations of single-celled organisms
all the way up to people that
communicate with each other through
chemistry and biochemistry passing
messages and energy back and forth these
are cell signaling networks and things
like your immune system and you might
rely on on the left here we have a rough
map of the human microbiome and then a
zoom in of just the gut microbiome
network and these are really very
complex things biology is very complex
the inherent properties of these
networks are that they are very local
hyper local they communicate via
chemistry so you have to wait for the
chemicals to go from one place to
another
they're also dynamic they change from
one moment to another if you wanted to
get a snapshot of something it would be
pretty hard to to see the same shape and
elements of the network from one minute
to the next
and there's self-organized this is not
something that's engineered it's
something that comes naturally out of
the interactions between all of these
biological components
despite that self-organization you can
see some structure in here they're not
random collections of things interacting
with each other without any sort of
order there is some order here but
probably the most important thing about
these networks is that you do not have
access to them if you wanted to know
right now whether or not your microbiome
is detecting any pollutants or if your
immune system is fighting off at the
beginning stages of a cold you don't
know the best you can do is you can get
a snapshot by sending away some samples
to a lab and you can find out in a
couple of weeks but this is a series of
networks that we as humans don't really
have access to in contrast at digital
networks are how we all share
information we're all familiar with the
Internet it's again contrasting with the
local biological networks this is a
global network it's it spans the earth
and beyond it's also instant so you get
to know information right away if you
want to look
the population of Denver you can find
out the population of Denver in a matter
of months it's also engineered and it's
human readable very very important that
things become readable the highest we
don't get to interact with them despite
the big differences the structures of
these networks biological networks and
digital networks are similar they're
both exponential scale networks with
some order within them but to truly
utilize biological networks we need to
find a way to get them access to our
digital networks again this is how we
share information something doesn't have
access to our digital network if your
heating system doesn't have a way of
getting information into the Internet
then you're stuck in an old twentieth
century approach towards understanding
biology this idea of coupling digital
networks with bio biological networks is
the Internet of biology and this is
something that's talked about out there
by several different people and it's
that idea that you're integrating the
biological networks that are local with
the internet which is global you're
taking something which is dynamic and
also providing instant access to it and
you're able to take a very complex
engineer Network and link it to a
complex emergent network so you might
want to use the Internet of biology to
ask questions like am I getting sick
right now is this food right here
healthy is this environment clean and
the information that's flowing from
organisms cells and people that interact
and bring biochemically with the
environment should to be able to tell
you the answers to those questions right
away now doing a connection actually
connecting the chemical relatively slow
biological networks with the instant
global network of the Internet is very
difficult and it requires some gateway
that's where kardea comes in
we don't actually mean you know in our
biology we build the network
and so that's going to be the primary
thing I'm talking to you today about the
biochemists that we work with build the
apps on the Internet of biology and the
engineers that we work with build the
tools that allow you to interact with
the Internet of biology but we build
this gateway in between to describe a
little bit of elements of these
different worlds that interacts together
we can look through some of these areas
here so for example wireless networking
allows that global communication and the
local portability of the internet the
combination of electronics fabrication
and personal devices allows you low-cost
access to the Internet and low-cost
access to the information wherever you
are
machine learning provides very powerful
tools for you to understand information
that might take you a long time to study
otherwise providing a little bit of
extra computational moved here to your
brain on the biological side genomics
provides information about what biology
could be or might be proteomics provides
information about what is currently
going on in biology the microbiome as an
example is a local biological network
that is an information exchange and
exchanges all sorts of different things
with agricultural networks and your own
wellness synthetic biology is how we
engineer of biological tools in this
area I am a nanotechnologist I don't
build nanobots
I do something much more powerful I work
with synthetic biologists so if the
Gateway if we're working the Gateway in
between the biological networks and the
digital networks
what is that gateway that is a digital
bio sensor so what is a bio sensor
there's an easy definition for a bio
sensor it's simply a device that
connects
biological or converts a biological
interaction into a machine readable
signal now typically this
is done without the use of extra
reagents like a label generally in this
kind of picture which which I like this
is a version of a picture that's been
floating around in the nanotechnology
community for a long time the biosensors
this alligator clip and if it's if you
can think of it like there's a wire that
stretches out from your computer or your
smartphone and just clips onto a protein
and tracks what it's doing the biosensor
is that alligator clip it's the thing
that allows you to see what the protein
is interacting with in the environment
is active is it not active isn't binding
to something that's not so understanding
really how about a sensor works we want
to start with the anatomy of a bio
sensor and this is important and often
misunderstood biosensors are made up of
multiple different pieces
there's the receptor the transducer and
the computer which also needs all the
software and the way that we look at the
data and understand it the receptors
here at the top I've drawn my physics
versions of proteins which are those
little orange pac-man's now the receptor
is the component that actually interacts
with the environment in a modern bio
sensor this is something like an
antibody or
DNA but in the beginning of biosensors
this was most often a polymer and in
reality today it's usually a combination
of synthetic and biological components
this is the part of the bio sensor that
gives it its specificity and sensitivity
it tells you how well your sensor is
able to detect the one thing you're
looking at without getting distracted
with a false positive negative and it
also tells you how low and how high
concentrations you can measure the key
for the rest of the biosensors system is
to work well with this receptor and to
get the most out of the chemistry that
it brings but it's not really realistic
to think that your device is going to
improve upon your biochemistry so it's
very important that this receptor layer
B be made well and be specific for the
application
you're trying to develop your bio sensor
or the transducer is the technology
component and often when you talk to
engineers they'll talk about this as
being the bio sensor but in reality it's
just part of the bio Center there's a
lot of different kinds of this
electrochemical and some of the other
ones I've listed here so some of the
things that you really want to think
about when you look at the different
technologies of transducer is what kinds
of receptors can be used on this
transducer because not every technology
is compatible with every type of biology
how is the receptor couples to the
transducer is this something that you
know can be done easily or is it require
a lot of work is this the kind of thing
that's going to be good for one type of
protein or one type of molecule or can
it be used generally and do you get the
full range of sensitivity and
selectivity when you're using particular
transducer with a particular set of
molecules does the technology itself
limit your reading in some way these are
the kind of things that people think
about when they're designing a bio
sensor and in the past these are the
kind of things that are limited the use
of the bio sensor in particular the
different technologies that you really
influence or rather control the size and
the cost and the overall capabilities of
the system so if you want something
that's portable a lot of technologies
aren't going to be appropriate if you
want something that's inexpensive a lot
of technologies are going to be
appropriate and so you really need to
figure out exactly where do the
different technologies there the last
part is the computer and this is what
provides access to the rest of the world
to your bio sensor and theoretically
everybody else answer today can make use
of powerful computational tools but the
reality is that that's not how
everything works and some bio sensor
technologies fit better with
computational tools than others one more
little bit of history here there's just
a little bit of history on biosensors
these is actually old technology it
started in 1956 with the Clark
this is something that allowed doctors
to measure oxygen levels and blood in
real time and that revolutionized
surgery so you can see here most of the
commercialization in biosensors was done
relatively recently so 1990 was when SPR
surface plasmon resonance biosensors
were commercialized by pharmacy of Pia
core this was the first big use of
biosensors outside of the
electrochemical biosensors that were
first developed in the fifties and since
then there have been commercial launches
of fiber-optic biosensors and now the
field effect biosensing biosensors it's
taken this evolution of different
biosensors to get to where we can talk
about the Internet of biology and
digital biosensors I'm gonna describe a
little bit of why it it is why it is
that we need this new fev type sensor to
talk about these things to start off
with Electrical biosensors the
electrochemical biosensors were first
developed are by far the most common
type of bio sensor out there so
typically these biosensors like the
Clarke electrode they measure things
like salt or dissolved gases and but the
major exception here is probably the
most common bio sensor in the world and
that is glucose monitoring so most of
the monitors that you use to check your
glucose level if you're diabetic
rely on some sort of electrochemical bio
sensor and so they're actually all over
the place they're inexpensive relatively
easy to use obviously they can be
handheld relatively fast the major
drawback of an electrochemical bio
sensor is that it requires some sort of
a charge transfer basically you need an
element of biology that acts like a
battery and that can work when you're
trying to measure oxygen or glucose or
salt but it doesn't work with most most
biology that's interesting or useful it
also generally requires relatively high
concentrations
now even with all of those limitations
you can still
the very powerful biosensor systems like
the ISTAT which is a handheld bio sensor
from avid I believe that allows you to
do a lot of different handheld
biosensing measurements it's not quite
exactly what we're talking about for a
digital bio sensor though because you're
not getting a lot of complex biological
interactions you're getting a snapshot
of some of the more energy transfer
related interactions Wow a more general
bio sensor would be in the past
something that would be an optical bio
sensor and what I'm showing here is a
diagram of an SPR system surface plasmon
resonance this is a really big system
really complex to use really expensive
and that's typical of a lot of optical
bio sensor systems optical biosensors
are very powerful they allow you to
measure almost any bio bio chemical
interaction when they were first
launched they were generally only
capable of measuring large protein
protein interactions but a skilled user
and measure just about anything these
days
they're very popular in research labs
and early-stage drug discovery in
particular but that's because that's
where you can find the the people with
the expertise and the budgets to use
them they are not the kind of thing that
you're gonna carry around in your pocket
they're much much larger digital
biosensors find the benefits of the
old-style electrochemical sensors with
the capabilities of optical biosensors
meaning a digital bio sensor is
relatively low cost relatively fast and
easy to use it can be handheld but it
can also measure any biological
interaction so now you have a tool that
allows you to look at protein protein
interactions small molecule interactions
that dissolve gas and salt interactions
basically anything that you that a cell
might be interested in can be monitored
by a digital bio sensor and it's in a
package that you can carry around in
your pocket so we
access to Portability and a large
biological range of measurements this
was only possible because of
nanotechnology and this may be actually
the first real enabling technology
created by the nanomaterial boom that
started at the start of the 20th century
I am a nanotechnologist so at this point
I am honorbound to give you a brief
history of nanotech in this area around
1990 was when field effect biosensing
the technology that drives digital
biosensors was first demonstrated in a
pre nanotechnology world it was first
used with silicon transistors and Wow
people were able to show that silicon
transistors could be used to measure
biological interactions they also were
able to show pretty clearly that silicon
was not going to work from a practical
point of view and any sort of device and
the reason for that is silicon just does
not play well with salt water and in
salt water is unfortunately the the
environment that most biology likes to
live in the corrosion that happens to
the silicon material when it's put into
blood or any any biological fluid
creates a barrier between the silicon
and the interesting biology that you
want to measure the result is that
people were frustrated and basically
decided this technology feels like
biosensing was stuck until a new
semiconducting material can be found
that would be able to operate in salt
water about 10 years after that the
first nano transistors were made and one
of the first applications of these
transistors was biosensors and these
used carbon nanotubes carbon nanotubes
unlike the silicon are stable in salt
water you can take a carbon nanotube
transistor and put it in whole blood and
the transistor
function this was a really exciting time
to be a nanotechnologist we were
developing all sorts of really
interesting measurements we were seeing
things in protein structure biochemistry
and real time dynamics of bio systems
that no one had ever seen before we got
to publish papers and great journals we
got to go to conferences and give talks
to act rooms and one of the reasons why
we were able to do that is no one else
could use these devices the problem with
the first generation of nano electronic
digital biosensors is that they were
only usable in a nanotechnology lab
Carlino tube transistors were very
difficult and the technology couldn't be
transitioned to Avaya lab only the
biologists that happen to be able to
collaborate with the nanotechnologist
could make progress so that led to some
disappointment and a loss of interest
until about 10 years later a graphene
biosensors were demonstrated and this
led to the second explosion of nano
electronic biosensors there was again a
lot of excitement over what could be
measured we did again a lot of really
great measurements but this time we also
felt like there was potential to reach
beyond the nanotechnology labs because
we we believed graphene could be
manufactured and turned into something
that would have operate outside of a
nanotechnology group something
manufacturable and commercializable and
in 2016 we got to the first use of a
commercial nanosensor a real digital bio
sensor in biology lab and i want to tell
you a little bit about that experience
because i think this is the first the
first time that a digital bio sensor was
actually used by a biologist so in 2016
we had a few customers who were
nanotechnologists and engineers who were
buying chips from us in the early days
of our of our commercial fabrication but
we didn't really have any biologists yet
and towards the end of 20
fifteen I was talking at the American
the American yes American Society of
cell biology conference and we were
presenting some measurements in house
that we'd been taking and I was
approached by a postdoc from Stanford
near and feet' who had a problem he
thought we could solve and nears problem
was that he had developed a peptide that
was specific to delta t kc r PK c delta
p k c delta is a kinase an enzyme that's
in builds up during blockage of blood
flow and then creates a lot of damage
once the flow is restored it's involved
in heart attacks and and the damage
that's created during a heart attack new
year's peptide is meant to block the
damage from happening by blocking a
particular domain called the PK name of
this delta he had proven that his
peptide worked in mice and his peptide
did stop the damage in in mice hearts
when PK c delta was activated during a
heart attack but his goal was to show
that it stopped that damage because of
the targeting targeting mechanism that
he designed and he couldn't show that
because pinky see delta is a very
short-lived protein this gets back to
that idea of the dynamism the the
dynamic nature of biology things change
very rapidly and most of our engineered
systems like a lot of past biosensors
and the internet rely on a stable
infrastructure and stable tools biology
doesn't work that way this is an enzyme
that's activated and stays around for a
couple of minutes and then and then is
recycled and so when you only have a few
minutes to try and measure something the
tools available to you are limited near
had tried to get the data in the lab
showing that he could specifically
target the
piqué domain of this enzyme but he
failed because the tools required him to
take measurements for longer period of
time than this enzyme is alive he
thought that our technology would be
able to help him take this measurement
much quicker because we have this
ability to combine instant measurements
with without adding extra complexity
from labels typically you might use a
label to do this type of measurement but
that requires development of a label and
addition of more reagents and a movement
away from what's really happening in the
biology to an abstraction of what's
happening with the label doing a direct
measurement of whether or not his
peptide bound to this kinase is what he
wanted to do so about a month after the
conference I traveled the Stanford and
spent an afternoon working with here I'm
trying to get the data and this is the
data that we got right away this is one
of those unique situations and science
that almost never happened when you sit
down to take a measurement and right
away you get great data we sat down we
got we put attached his peptide to the
surface of our chips and we put in
different solutions containing his
protein PK C Delta and a control protein
PK c epsilon which is very similar to PK
C Delta but without the domain he
designs his peptide to bind to in this
graph here on the right on the left the
target is the PK C Delta and the
controls KC axial we got this data in an
afternoon and this was data that in
taking he'd been working on getting for
about six months so this very quickly
led near to a bunch of other work he
finished up a bunch of projects became
our first real biologists customer
published some papers now he's a
professor at bar-ilan University and his
peptides and I think are being developed
into pharmaceuticals which is great so
this is what digital biosensors can do
they can help help you gain insight into
dynamic hard to measure elements of
biology very rounded
I'm gonna get into some more
applications later but in the very
beginning this was most useful towards
researchers to have particularly heart
problems before we get to that I haven't
yet explained how field effective
biosensing works and now that I've shown
you a little bit of what field effect
biosensing does I want to show you how
fields are biosensing functions this is
a diagram of our device so in the
beginning we have our same orange
pac-man shaped proteins that's our
biology it's the biological components
could be an antibody could be a peptide
as an ears case could be a piece of DNA
those are chemically bound to graphene
which forms the basis for a transistor
just just an electrical device to
measure current the sample is introduced
on top of the vial biology and graphing
and this actually forms part of the
circuit the circuit is completed after
the sample is added electrochemical
controls are used to control the voltage
in the sample the liquid that's put on
top of the biology and that liquid could
be anything we've done whole blood urine
or buffers like you'd find in a research
lab the biology now that's sitting in
between the sample and the graphene is
sitting in between a controlled voltage
and sample and it controlled voltage
measuring material and the grounding any
biochemical interactions that change how
that attached protein layer attached a
receptor layer this forms anything
binding or interacting with our biology
attached to the graphene changes how the
voltage is passed from the top the
sample part to the bottom graphing part
that allows us to instantly detect
biochemical interactions we've published
a few papers on this most recently in
nature scientific reports there's some
links here on this
Paige the scientific reports is open
access and is a good summary of how our
system works why does this work I am a
physicist and a nanotechnologists and so
I think that I'm required by some sort
of secret physics world to have an
equation and at least every presentation
that I give so this is my required
equation here's how this works from a
from a physics point of view the base
can of the conductor the graphene is our
conduction channel and that forms the
basis for our circuit what we're doing
is we're changing the gate on the ground
so in this equation above there's a
whole bunch of stuff in the beginning
which relates to the really basically
the resistance of the graphene and then
there's some terms inside that those
parentheses that talk about what the
gate is doing the bulk solution is
setting the overall gate voltage that
gate voltage is modified by two things
the double-layer region and the don and
equilibrium region in the old ion
sensitive field effect transistor work
you would only have the double-layer
region and that double-layer region is
where the different salts are moving
around back and forth on top of the
ground and it's right up close to the
surface and it's usually too small of an
area to do any significant BioSense
again the Don an equilibrium region is
referring to the area that encompasses
all of your biology as well as any
membrane or or synthetic polymer area
that we use to immobilize the protein
DNA the the biological receptor to the
surface altogether what you can think of
in this Don in equilibrium region is
that there is a layer on top of the
graphene that consists of some receptors
and some stuff that holds those
receptors in place and those those
materials have different salt
concentrations than the both solution.i
Sault moves back and forth due to
binding of some event or some other
biochemical interaction we see a change
in the donning potential which is a
voltage that we read on the graphing as
if it was an extra gate voltage this
donning potential is the same thing that
you see on a cell membrane when you
don't have any sort of activity pumping
it so it's the same sort of voltage you
might get at rest and cell all together
this is what causes our our gate
response and again our most recent paper
describes this in a lot more detail this
is what our bio sensor architecture
actually looks like so on the left there
that's a picture of one of our
biosensors it's about the size of one of
your fingers it's pretty small maybe the
size of a glass slide it contains in the
middle a little circle that's where you
little early and on that circle there's
a micro patterns a sensor array that
sensor array contains the on-chip
potential control and as you can see
here those little blue rectangles in the
middle of that picture those are the
sensors there's 15 of them on every chip
this is where the measurements actually
take place so they're pretty small this
is our standard architecture I'm going
to show you some pictures of some of our
other chips towards the end of the top
this is what the sensor system looks
like the important thing to get from
this slide really is that the size of
the overall system is really about the
size of a large cell phone so it is
something you can carry around in your
pocket I've carried you surrounding my
pocket it's meant to be a personal bench
top tool it's very easy to use power to
be a USB there's not a lot of extra
stuff you have to carry around with you
it's got some nice specifications here
in terms of large dynamic range and
small number amount of material
requirements but the basic idea is that
this is pretty small there's more
customer publications links to them here
the people that have been publishing in
editions and years initial publications
I want to give you one example here of I
think a more relevant measurement to the
idea of the Internet of biology this is
taking an Eliza and converting it to
field effect biosensing and Eliza
measurement is probably the most common
type of measurement done to measure a
biological interaction in a diagnostic
setting or or a monitoring type setting
it's a labeled measurement it means that
you're going to take usually something
like an antibody you're gonna bind an
antigen to it from the sample and then
you're going to bind a label to that
antigen and the label might be something
that flores's or changes color some
optical measurement that you can you can
run doing an Eliza is pretty slow but
very very reliable
once it's worked out so it's a great
it's great tool for current Diagnostics
we took an Eliza for il-6 which is a
information biomarker it's used a lot of
different tests and we took that kid
from life technology is just a standard
kit for il-6 detection we attached the
antibody from that kit that binds il-62
large chips so you can see here the
bottom this is the typical workflow for
us you take a baseline measurement you
mobilize your receptor layer in this
case we used an antibody against il-6
you had a blocking layer which fills in
any gaps that the antibody may not have
filled on the ground you run an
association meaning you try and see if
you can detect the binding of the il-62
the surface and a disassociation you
look forward to wash off and those
stairs tell you a lot about how tightly
things have bent we used a lot of you
know small numbers of material for this
the important thing here is we did
use the label so we used about half the
reagents of the aisle of the aisle 6 kit
but we're trying to get the same result
we also wanted this to happen in 15
minutes instead of the usual several
hour measurement this is what some of
the data looks like here this is
multiple chips this is just the
immobilization so this is putting the
antibody down on the surface and there's
a lot of steps to that you start with
your baseline you have to activate the
the surface of the chip now you do some
rinsing you put your antibodies down you
block it quench any active chemistry
meaning you basically anything on the
surface that's going to react to
something that future you you react it
ahead of time so that's it's inert and
it's not gonna change anything during
the measurement and then you rinse again
it's an important to note that at this
step the chip is stable it has an
antibody on it covalently down to the
chip and we can vacuum pack those chips
and store them and then use them any
time we'd like in the future this allows
us to print chips for for any sort of
interactions we want to measure well
ahead of time in this case we move on to
the measurements here's what the
different concentrations of il-6 the the
biomarker we're looking for do when we
put them onto the chip in a normal Eliza
measurement you would be seeing
individual data points not data over
time it's pretty rare to look at data
over time in the in the first minute of
a sample being introduced to a service
so this real-time nature of a biosensor
gives us a lot of insight into what
happens we're beginning of an
interaction the important things here
that we have duplicated the limit of
detection of the Eliza so we took half
the reagents a fraction of the time this
was 5 minutes not 15 a fraction of the
time to run the FE be compared to the
Eliza and and we can see the same 2 gram
per milliliter limit of detection get
from the more worked out more lively
tested
much more expensive Alaska the limit of
quantitation we can quantify a little
bit broader really that's because our
our analytical software might be a
little more powerful the real-time
nature of the data gives us a little
more assurance of what we're looking at
and we're able to use small volumes so
we can use more material to get to a
higher concentration than you can with a
typical alignment the important thing
here again is that we've duplicated if
the effectiveness of realiza
using our system but done so in a much
shorter time you can also use it for
some other things this is a data from
one of our papers where we collaborated
with the CDC on demonstrating detection
of Zika most diagnostic tests out there
look for a response from your immune
system they're trying to trigger some
response from your immune system you see
hey is yours your body trying to fight
this off right now we were able to
actually look and see hey is there Zika
virus in this sample at a level
hopefully before your immune system
would even start fighting it off the
sooner you can detect something the
better particularly something like
Seether and what we were able to show is
that we could detect Zika and relevant
concentrations in the serum using our
bio sensor without a label just directly
detecting it in the paper we also showed
that we were able to distinguish between
the Zika protein that we were looking at
and the similar protein that's used or
that's found in a common interference of
Zika tests and satellites now this is
not a diagnostic this was just a proof
of concept but it shows the direction
the technology to take we can detect
viruses right away we can detect
biomarkers there are related
inflammation this this slide here shows
we can detect drugs in people's in serum
so this was part of a therapeutic drug
monitoring effort that
was funded in part by DARPA where we
looked at taking an Optima against a
small molecule and demonstrating that we
could detect it in both buffer and in
serum detecting drugs in real-time in
someone's blood is really important for
dosing dosing of antibiotics or
chemotherapy drugs and things like that
it's important often not to overdose
people but also not under dose them and
the current ways of doing these kinds of
tests are really really difficult on the
healthcare system being able to do a
real-time monitoring of the levels of
drugs in someone's system will be very
helpful so this is the another direction
the technology is headed that's some of
the examples of the different types of
technology or the applications that are
already being worked on here there's
other applications that you can find out
about and actually some other lab
rootstock so I'll get to those a little
bit at the end too so before we finish
up a little bit on how we were able to
do this if you go back to what I was
saying about the nanotechnology
different boom and bust cycles and where
we were stuck ten years ago was about
not being able to move the devices out
of the nanotechnology claps and there's
a lot in the nanotechnology literature
about different ways of making devices
and what we did is we threw all that out
and we started over with a fresh process
something that would work in a
commercial facility we developed
something that we call our protect and
exposed manufacturing process and that
allowed us to get to a point where we
have predictable yield cost and
performance the kinds of things that you
know really want in your biological
monitoring devices we did this there's
three main pillars one is we took our
own control of in-house graphic and
handling and there's a big difference
between graphing handling and graphing
growth just having access to the
material graphene isn't enough you need
to know how to use it
and because we mastered how to use it
our cost per area for graphing is less
than the cost per area that for silicon
so when we make devices the amount we
spend on a particular chip in silicon is
higher than the amount we spend on
gravity we have moved into the
commercial fabrication we actually use a
commercial MEMS foundry to do a lara
wafer construction and we have a lot of
QA we do a lot of QA processes at
multiple points in our and our
manufacturing flow and we automate as
much of that as we can this focus on
manufacturing has allowed us to create a
couple of different form factors and the
small chip size our small transistor
size allows us to really have unlimited
form factor options the chips I showed
you are the middle chip that three
channel chip that's our standard one
that's sold through their med that we
also have a multiplex 40 channel chip
that we've built and a chip that has a
16 byte by the three channel chip that
one has chips that are very very small
smaller than the fingernail on your
pinky and are designed to be used in an
array this is just an example of the
different kinds of form factors that we
can build on chips into this flexibility
and processing allows us to start
working on a lot of applications beyond
the traditional laboratory use and even
diagnostic applications that we've been
looking at with biosensors so far really
the big ones here are things like fields
employable sample testing personalized
monitoring devices the rapid and complex
nature of data that we're able to
provide opens us up to really using
machine learning in a meaningful way
machine learning in biology is difficult
because a lot of the measurement tools
use labels and other abstraction x' away
from the real biological interactions
you find out a lot about the labeling
technology not so much about the biology
moving that
and providing direct access to what the
biologists doing in real time we really
think that the machine learning
capabilities that are being developed
right now will have a powerful effect on
understanding the data that comes out of
our biosensors all together this may
lead to a future in which we were able
to do in-home diagnostic testing for any
number of different things to do that
like I said we're not building the whole
Internet of biology we're building the
Gateway we need partnerships to actually
build out the different applications
biochemists who understand the
applications engineers who understand
devices we have two big partnerships
right now manna medical diagnostics
they've been selling the agile r100 the
story about Mir has led to Nana Minh and
the use of this tool in research labs
academic labs and pharmaceutical labs
looking at early stage of our discovery
nano sense is our other big partnership
they've developed their CRISPR chip and
this is revolutionizing the way that
people think about detecting DNA and
particularly detecting DNA using CRISPR
dr. Iran who has led the effort there is
actually going to be talking on laberd's
so go look for her talk after you finish
this one we have a lot of other
partnerships in the pipeline that are
not able to talk about them right now I
would be really interested in talking
with anyone who thinks they have an idea
and would like to partner up and with
that I'd like to thank you for your
attention and look forward to hearing
about hearing from you about any
questions you might have or comments
Thanks and thank you dr. Goldsmith for
that informative presentation I'd also
like to thank elaborates for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a final reminder dr. Goldsmith will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we will see
you
next time bye-bye